time for another game spot news update
I'm your host Chris waters with the
launch of PlayStation TV less than a
month away in North America Sony today
announced that almost 700 games will be
available for the system when it
launches PS TV can play many PlayStation
Vita games either through downloading
the game or inserting the actual game
card and it can be used to play digital
PlayStation 1 and PSP games through
remote play it can also be used to
stream PlayStation 4 games from one ps4
console in your home on to a separate TV
Sony's game streaming service
PlayStation now will eventually arrive
for PS TV allowing you to stream
PlayStation 3 titles onto the device PS
now just recently entered open beta on
ps3 but sony has not announced when it
will arrive for PS TV PS TV launches in
North America on october fourteenth the
standalone system goes for 99 bucks and
you can get bundles that include a
dualshock 3 controller 8 gigabyte memory
card and a copy of the lego movie
videogame four hundred and forty dollars
will of course have a full breakdown of
PS TV next month when it launches here
in North America and for all your
GameSpot news updates keep it tuned to
gamespot com folks thank you very much